la halle du marché n'existe plus depuis
plus d'une semaine les ouvriers
s'attellent à la destruction de la
structure norvégienne des travaux qui
auraient dû débuter en novembre dernier
ça avance bien ce qui nous permet de
déconstruire notre marché qui avait subi
un incendie et de procéder comme on peut
le voir derrière nous donc au tri des
matériaux le bois d'un côté les métaux
ferreux de l'autre et tout ce qui est
donc pierre la halle du marché
accueillait une quarantaine de
commerçants
elle a été touchée par un incendie dans
la nuit du 30 au 31 juillet 2019 pour
beaucoup de morts pas yann mort passe
bien la vision encore de cette halle
incendié rester quelque chose de pénible
donc là enfin une nouvelle page va
pouvoir s'écrire la concertation auprès
des habitants des commerçants et des
clients s'est terminée en fin d'année
2020 si les plans du futur marché ne
sont pas encore dessiné la ville
souhaite qu'ils soient couverts et que
les étals reste fixe